I think there will be a lot of probably
consulting services and and you know we
try to do as good a job as we can on
informing people of what this
information means for them but I could
see cottage industries sprouting up that
help people really absorb the
information even more and have it at
more of a personal level so if you you
get your data online but you want to go
and talk to someone in person there
could be these Consulting Group's and
and genetic counselors who create their
services around these whole genome data
sets and so they'll they'll have to get
up to speed on the educational side of
it but I think as this becomes more part
of society will see that that more
personalized service become more and
more prevalent